if you need me as Joey fix courageous
cancer battle continues her husband Rory
feek speaks exclusively with et about
what the future holds
I'm Sophia Lacy and we caught up with
Rory by email he told us that he won't
continue performing without his wife
with a new gospel album coming
exclusively to Cracker Barrel on
February 12th Rory tells et this is the
last record that Joey and I will ever
get to make and the last songs will ever
sing together I have no desire to go on
singing or performing without her
he's with me now the couple's daughter
Indiana will turn 2 in February and her
birth is featured in the video for Joey
and Rory's Grammy nominated song if I
needed you Rory tells us that Joey would
Rock baby indeed asleep with the hymns
on their new album and even taught her
how to sing along in sign language on
one of the tracks
Joey singing these songs is a big part
of in Dee's life so far and I know that
these songs will go on to be very
important to her as she grows up and is
able to hear Joey still singing them to
her